here we go I've written down the
four-sided cosign expansion and we use
the first one because I constructed this
question deliberately to fix the first
one here's how I got underneath where
you've written the first model do you
see why what you've got over here
matches what you have over here right
I'm actually going to write the exam on
people for example I have one that root
3 on 2 sine X plus 3 on 2 coz X okay so
I looked at the question and I saw okay
well this thing here it must have come
from some expansion okay can anyone tell
me why I could have but it would have
been silly to choose this as my
expansion to give you this have a look
what's missing or what does it have that
I don't want to have in here there's a
minus sign of it all right we don't
stand this you get a private right there
and the question doesn't have a by this
idea now if you plot it you could choose
this and then just have a double
negative but why would you do that right
you're just making life hard for
yourself not really you get a double
negative but you'll find that these
angles that you get over here they end
up getting bigger we go big um and it's
just me smaller equals a nicer and
easier to work so if I for example give
you this I said okay y equals sine X
minus 2
cod X when you have a look at this you
say all right which one is first it's
sign first
and what's the sign in between the two
the operation - so therefore that would
fit here if I saw sine X minus 2 plus X
my brain would say all right try this
one you can try this one but it's just
going to be negatives where they don't
born
music if you've got a negative you might
as well use it if sine X is the first
function you use this guy all this
caravans mother
if colors x1 the other head is what
comes first
okay and I know I can rewrite this if I
wanted to but it closed X is what came
first and I'm going to use one of these
okay I know if I said to you y equals
root two close xu+ let's go root three
sine X by the way the reason why you see
so many virtues then root three slangin
is because the exact values 15 functions
they have risen root three and refused
inside them right for that's why they
come up like really if you saw that
cosine is first so do you see these guys
have cosine first you guys have sine
fest so I'm going to use one of these
the sign in the middle the plus so which
of these looks like little use this one
here - gives me a plus in the middle
because cosine does that mean swapping
so if I saw that question
eg root 2 coz X minus the plus + hundred
three sine X this is the form that I
would choose right so look at what is
first we could watch first and then pay
attention to the sign can you give me an
example of something that would fit this
you can make something up even if I am
to context - I hope that was really
really original kind of gonna just for
the favor I'm just going to smile even
change it to that I don't know if you
can see the important result which
function comes first which function
comes first the cause or the sign and in
secondly what's the sign in the middle
therefore which one does it leave now
this signal you will notice why wait a
second wait a second
something like this right this guy Kia
sign X is written first at the moment
but is no reason I can't write it the
other way
can I write this as 3 or 2 cot X plus 3
sine X I can which means if if I hadn't
reordered it which one of these would I
use and use the plot line one note root
3 on 2 first time no just regular 3 on 2
cos x plus root 3 on 2 silence ok now
here's what's interesting this is
clearly the same function this function
and this function it hasn't changed
but I can rewrite it using a different
auxilary angle or I could rewrite it as
this or as this right so I'm actually
going to leave it as an exercise to you
if we started this all from scratch but
instead of writing our sine X plus alpha
you saw our way there because at the
front instead of our side whatever I'm
going to choose our cause and what's
going to be here the middle X minus
alpha let's see I'm gonna let you have a
go and see what happens
at the other end and if it's what you
expect you